Before Senator and Former Attorney General of California Kamala Harris
was chosen as Joe Biden's running mate in the 2020 election,
she played a role in a campaign to force a website called Backpage.com
to stop operating on the grounds that it was used to facilitate sex trafficking.
Backpage.com needs to shut itself down when it has created as its business model
the profiting of the selling of human beings and the purchase of human beings.
Good businesses such as Craigslist understood how it could be misabused and mishandled,
and they shut that aspect of their business model down.
Backpage needs to do the same.
We didn't kowtow, we don't tattle tale.
It would give the lie to our entire lives our entire career of being journalists
if the government could come in and put their stubby little fingers in our chest
and make us ask for our mommy. It ain't gonna happen.
In the course of her prosecution of Backpage's founders Michael Lacey and James Larkin,
Harris spread misinformation about its practices she co-filed criminal charges
that were quickly dismissed but
succeeded at garnering headlines and
photo ops that raised her political
profile
in reality backpage.com had become a
powerful tool for law enforcement to
catch sex traffickers
because of the cooperation and
commitment of the site's founders to the
cause
whom harris and many other state
attorneys general and politicians
had painted as villains backpage.com
is nothing more than a front for pimps
and
child sex traffickers to stop this
online child sex trafficking that's
being facilitated by sites
such as this harris had supported
anti-sex trafficking bills when she was
district attorney of san francisco but
it was in october 2016
after she was elected california
attorney general that she co-filed
criminal charges against lacey and
larkin
as well as backpage ceo carl farrar
though accused of running a website used
by sex traffickers the charges were
quickly tossed out because lacey and
larkin were clearly protected by section
230 of the communications decency act
known as the internet's first amendment
which says that an online platform
isn't responsible for many types of
content posted by its customers
according to lacie and larkin the
charges were so thin there was no reason
to file them
except as a stunt to raise her public
profile she does this
right before the election and inside the
courtroom there was a jail cell
they filmed us in the jail cell
and then broadcast it on the evening
news
so harris gets to have her name in all
the papers right before the election
saying that she's the one who helped
take down these people that everyone for
years has been characterizing as
these big evil sex traffickers it was a
publicity stunt
lacie and larkin spent four days in a
sacramento jail
she knew the section 230 barred her from
bringing these charges but she brought
them anyway
and of course a judge threw them right
out so harris filed another set of
charges against the three men
harris was trying to say that drawer and
lacie and larkin by virtue of having
this sight and knowing that sometimes
you know
bad things happen there that they were
guilty these other pimping charges later
get dismissed too
journalist elizabeth nolan brown writes
about sex workers in the criminal
justice system and she's been covering
the lawsuit against backpage
which recently got rescheduled to 2021
because of covet 19.
brown revealed secret justice department
memos showing prosecutors spent years
trying to build a child sex trafficking
case against backpage
but failed to uncover compelling
evidence of criminal intent
or pattern or reckless conduct regarding
minors
instead justice department officials
found backpage was remarkably responsive
to law enforcement requests
and proactively sent ads containing
minors to authorities
the memos revealed a world far outside
the characterization harris and other
politicians attorneys general
and activists had been pushing for years
about backpage
to be clear this is a crime it is a
crime
that is rightly punishable by
incarceration
in prison on january 10 2017
harris who had been elected the junior
senator from california participated in
hearings on backpage
these individuals must be held
accountable these allegations must be
given
voice and we have to do all that is
right to make sure that we as a civil
society
protect always the most vulnerable among
us and not take advantage of them
assuming nobody will care these hearings
have made clear
we care but as harris and other senators
characterized backpage as complicit in
sex trafficking
justice department memos revealed law
enforcement officers the country over
were working with backpage employees
taking seminars on how to use the site
from backpage lawyers and coming to rely
on the site for sex trafficking
investigations
a 2012 memo described the backpage data
as a goldmine of information for
investigators
so many different people put on this
huge show of making them the villain in
this
a lot of people in government actively
made the calculation to
make life more dangerous for both sex
workers and sex trafficking victims
in order to satisfy this crusade that
they were on publicly
on april 6 2018 the fbi raided the homes
of lacey and larkin
and accused them of running a website
that facilitated prostitution their
trial is scheduled to take place in
january 2021.
it's hard to make us feel guilty we're
not guilty
okay you can't you can't talk me into it
it's an evergreen political issue
always works they're waiting to be
governors
or senators presidents that's what that
was all about